get some rules to follow there are no
secrets in the city of New York there's
cameras everywhere phone records parking
tickets
someone saw something heard something
the city always knows
Sam got shot in Central Park
we're like basically best friends
we're gonna find who did this story how
do we figure out who the connection is
Samantha is
almost
[Music]
police detectives were here
where were you on July 4th
I don't know how I don't know why but
this girl was connected to us
you guys know Sam you might know why she
left me I got shot Sam was one of us
whatever Sam knew I want to know too
[Music]
she left me clues she was on to
something I think I'm the only one that
can figure this out we gotta learn more
about these people
more Generations you're hiding something
when we started this revolution we knew
it would have a cost
you're not the only one with secrets
[Music]
thank you